thank you
[Music]
this is Star Talk
Neil deGrasse Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and Today's show is going
to be things you thought you knew
and Old Timers out there know there's
only one person I do that with and
that's chat check nice yes good to have
you man always a pleasure all right so
you're ready to have things you thought
you knew explained yes because we could
do millions of these
if the criteria is
I don't know
you've got you future-proofed this
there will be no shortage of topics my
friend
all right let's let's get to this I
occasionally get questions about the
naming of things in my field
all right and let's take for example the
names of the Moon the planets and their
moons all right and had you ever
wondered how we get these names
not really but I I mean
I figured somebody looked up and said
I'm gonna call it that
because somebody did it right because
for me it had been like you know Jupiter
and then Jupiter a b c d you know
Jupiter one Jupiter two Jupiter like you
know that's because you have no
imagination right there well
that goes so so here we go so the
planets are named they all have Roman
Latin names basically okay and so the
name that they're sort of Roman gods
Mercury you know the messenger god
Mercury is the fastest moving planet
Venus is quite beautiful in the evening
Sky
um that object got named for Venus the
goddess of love and beauty
um and then also in the sky with Mars
which is red the color of blood so the
warrior God got named after that planet
or that planet got named after the
warrior God and let's keep going you
have Jupiter
[Music]
those are the plants known to the
Ancients and then later would be
discovered Neptune Uranus and Neptune
right and the thing about Uranus was
both that was the first
it was the first time anyone discovered
a planet it was William Herschel
back in the in the 1700s and it was like
all the other planets were just known
because they're just in the sky there's
not the person who discovered them
anyone who looked up noticed them so no
one is on record for discovering Mercury
Venus Mars Jupiter or Saturn
but Uranus got discovered and it got
discovered by William Herschel
and no one had discovered and therefore
no one had actually named a planet in
modern times wow so he's a good one he
tried to figure out what to name it and
so so he did the right thing okay he
named it after his principal funder
that's what scientists do wow artists do
the same thing they draw in the in the
in the background the the benefactor or
whatever you know the sponsor of the
painting that makes the rich folks feel
good right so uh so he he named this new
star after King George
okay
all right no that's the King George
that's of the American Revolution that
same King George because this is the
late 18th late 1700s and so that's the
same George that John Hancock signed his
big signature large enough for him to
read and same George in the in Hamilton
that same George yeah correct that same
King George so who by the way that King
George God could he was a show stealer
he was good
so I have books from that period so late
1700s early 1800s where the the
enumeration of planets is very clear
it's but we know Earth is a planet right
so Mercury Venus Earth that since
Copernicus we knew that Earth is a
planet as an object that goes around the
Sun so we have Mercury Venus Earth Mars
Jupiter Saturn
George and George George of course
and George right I have books that list
the planets in that order with those
names and
this was you look back and say what the
but what what
you know and so so
God we should have left that
I'm telling you right now that would be
the best thing in the world one day we
are going to get to George
with our greatest of Technology greatest
of Technology we sell one day set foot
upon George
instead of Uranus I'm sorry Uranus we
could have went with George's ass
planet
planet George's ass you're gonna say it
with a British accent right exactly
Planet George's ass
I'm sad I'm so terribly sorry
I say one day we shall get to George's
arms I say my soul chapter oh boy one
day we'll get there so looking forward
to being firmly planted in George's
okay stop that's enough okay
no no no no no no okay okay so it would
take a little while but clearer heads
would Prevail and how do you tell the
discoverer of a planet that he has to
unname it after his King this is very
tentative you know diplomatic moments
here
and so finally we landed on oranus
oranos which at from what I have read is
similarly pronounced in
um in both Greek and and Latin in Roman
um
it's the same word all right so it's
actually a crossover name between the
the Roman and the Greek okay that's cool
so that I'll show up later in a minute
so so and after that we get to Neptune
that is a you know Roman god of the seas
and this sort of thing and then when
Pluto was discovered when everyone
believed it was a planet that um Pluto
is the god of the underworld and it's
Roman so there you have it all right so
you might say well what about the Greeks
in the western Traditions they were
pretty significant in what they
contributed to all of this it's not just
the Romans right Romans are like Johnny
come lately compared to the Greeks yeah
and so we said okay
in our Western astronomical traditions
we will honor not only the Romans with
planet names we will honor the Greeks
with moon names
aha okay there we go so all moons
essentially there's some exceptions here
I can get to or moons in the solar
system are named after Greek
characters
in the life of the Greek counterpart
to the Roman god after whom the planet
is named gotcha are you with me on that
I'm with you on that so basically you
take the Roman right you find a God and
then you say okay how's that translate
into a Greek god and now we got a name
for a moon no I mean no right no no no
no no you got you got you got almost all
of it almost so you got the Roman god
right ask what is the Greek god
counterpart to that Roman god
okay now you look at characters in the
life of the Greek god ah gotchas and
those are the names of the moons right
because otherwise you would end up with
just two Gods two Gods every two friends
of the coin right yeah but what would be
a planet wouldn't be a moon that
wouldn't be right that wouldn't be right
yeah you'd be pissing off some powerful
God so let me give you a list of some of
these moves okay Mercury doesn't have
any moons and uh neither does Venus okay
and let's skip over Earth for a moment
we'll get back to Earth so what's next
Mars Mars has two moons
and they're they're pretty
sorry moons just they're like a dozen
miles across they're not even spherical
they're embarrassments they really are
yeah people wondering whether they've
just captured asteroids I was gonna say
that sounds like a rock that's yeah
that doesn't really sound like the Moon
it sounds like a rock that got lost
a wayward Rock a wayward Rock somebody
lost their rocks exactly
so so the Martian moons are called
Phobos and Deimos
Phobos and demos yes Phobos and demos as
I have read in the in the in the Greek
Traditions that's the name of the each
of the two horses
that drives the Chariot of Mars across
the sky I gotcha Phobos and demos yes
which by the way demos is a really cool
name demos yeah yeah it totally is
wasted on a rock
it is that's cooler name is demos is you
wasted it on a rock yeah it looks like
an Idaho Potato it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing but that's all it's got so
in fact uh one of the uh Mars rovers I
forgot which was in the path of a Phobos
or demo a Phobos Eclipse right
so it's got a picture of Phobos passing
in front of the Sun and it's just this
outline of an Idaho Potato deep within
the full disk of the sun it's
embarrassing yeah that is it was like it
couldn't even cover the whole sun
because it's so little and it's not even
round so anyway let's keep going it's
what comes after Mars we get to Jupiter
aha so uh Jupiter it's four brightest
moons we're named they call the Galilean
moons Galileo first saw them through his
telescope and then described them but
this is uh let me remember we have IO
Ganymede Callisto and I forgot one
uh Callisto Academy IO and
don't look at me
I hope you're not helping me help a
brother out yeah you're not waiting for
me to jump in
you once you got past Ganymede I was
just like oh [ __ ] how could I forget
Europa my gosh right which is the star
of the movie 2010. so um uh IO Callisto
Ganymede and Europa those are the four
biggest moons of Jupiter's I lost count
is probably near somewhere around 100
moons or more because every time we get
closer to it we see other tiny little
rocks and what distinguishes a moon from
just like a knot Moon you know if it's
just if it's orbiting and it's bigger
than a dust particle is it a moon can
you be in moon no matter how little you
are this is a debate and I'm not going
to bring that up here but I'm just going
to say those are the four big ones and
those are the ones that kind of really
matter when you see Jupiter through a
telescope there they are okay nice and
there's four of them they go around
Jupiter and Galileo when he first saw
them he said oh they're Stars near
Jupiter and then he looked later on and
he says wait the stars have mooned move
he called him the gout the the the the
the Jupiter Stars right and of course
why would you think you're discovering a
moon this isn't you're coming out of out
of nowhere and landing on this
information and so he was able to see
that they moved around they orbited
Jupiter oh my gosh that meant us Earth
was not the center of all motion look at
that yeah
this this was devastating to people who
wished it were otherwise and the Jupiter
Stars sounds like a really bad
basketball team
really it does it's a bad any kind of
team right yes exactly bad soccer team
right
so now let me take you to
Uranus
right okay
there was a pact
so as not to piss off the Brits who are
very powerful in the late the 1700s okay
all right they're one of the most
powerful forces the world had ever seen
particularly with their Naval power okay
so
you're gonna piss off the Brits and King
George what are you gonna do so here's
what they did here's what they did we
said okay we will make an exception of
the Greek rule
for the planet Uranus
and we will name the moons of Uranus
after fictional characters
in the plays of Shakespeare
oh
okay I have never heard this that's ever
so this threw a bone back to the Brits
so that they can rest easily that their
King was stripped from the name of the
planet and it had and it became a Roman
god Council wait a minute a
constellation prize no oh oh God
yeah that was good Chuck that was good
I gotta hand it to you so
what are some names we have Porsche
p-o-r-t-i-a remember Porsche from your
Shakespeare okay um do a lot of
characters from A Midsummer's Night
Dream because that's a very quite a
fantastical
storytelling going on there among the
moon names we have uh umbriel okay
Titania
Miranda Miranda is the lead character in
The Tempest okay we have Ariel Oberon
all right so puck
Desdemona all all these moons have names
drawn from Shakespeare
no that is that is really stunning
because I mean I can't believe that
that's just something that everybody
should know because it's so like almost
It Feels So Random
yeah well it's a little bit of History
yeah it's fun history it's not science
so much as it is just it's the
intersection of science taking place
embedded in our culture yeah yeah so now
you go out to the outer planets by the
way Pluto the first moon was discovered
around Pluto it was named Sharon or I
think in the Greek is Karen uh and Karen
is the ferry boat driver who carries
your soul across the river sticks to
Hades makes sense Pluto god of the
underworld well yeah it's what it's
Hades that's the so you go to the Greek
side of that so make a long story short
so this is the the the origin stories of
the names of the moons and in the very
later years when there are many more
moons discovered and you run out of
incidental characters in the life of
Greek and Roman gods by the way we had
many because they LED complex and
interesting social lives right so
there's a lot of characters you could
draw from but in modern times a more
inclusive sensibility has descended upon
us and so now there are there are there
are names of of of of gods and other
um uh other Spiritual Beings fictional
beings in from other cultures not just
Greek and Roman when we fully flesh out
all the names of all the moons so that's
a that's a that's that's solar system
moons 101. chuck oh man that's I'm
telling you that was really cool uh
however from now on I'm sorry I I have
to call Uranus
George's ass
Chuck we gotta take a quick break but
when we come back guess what I have more
explaining to do excellent
all right when StarTalk returns
Chuck we're back
yes we're going to take a look at the
Moon okay we looked at the Moon a lot
lately but but we're not done all right
I'm not finished with it
okay okay can you handle it oh yes
no
the Moon is so mysterious for so many
people for so many reasons and it's so I
mean and it's so romantic yes it's all
of the above it's spooky and romantic
spooky romantic it's poetic in many
respects yes you know it's in so many
paintings like you know
yeah and and it's it's it's a it's a
fundamental part of the symbol for Islam
this is the Crescent Moon with crescent
moon with Venus in the sky next to it so
yeah the Moon is important
and so a couple of things uh there's an
old saying I know that was Venus well
okay it's an evening or Morning Star
right and it would be if it's bright
enough it's generally going to be Venus
Venus right but the
um
it's it's rare that there's another
really cool star next to it and Venus is
always in the sky either with the waning
crescent or the waxing crescent so
typically that's Venus in practice it's
Venus and by the way it's really cool to
see it when it's a certain time of night
and it really isn't quite like all the
way dark and it's it's called Twilight
chuck oh use the word no
what do you call it when it's night but
not quite dark did I just invent
something
and you know this this stuff around us
at all times that you know it goes in
your lungs and you push it out
and that big yellow ball that gives us
light that I'm so glad you woke up today
yes
out of your 40-year coma yes yes but
Twilight uh Venus at Twilight is I mean
it's and and you can see it with the
naked eye and it's like it really looks
like somebody turned on the light in the
sky yeah yeah and and a little known
fact because Venus orbits the Sun closer
than we orbit the Sun okay
Venus will never stray too far away from
wherever the sun is on the sky
it's not going to end up behind us with
the sun in front of us right it's going
to be near the Sun so that's why you'll
typically notice Venus just after sunset
in Twilight or just Before Sunrise so in
evening Twilight so dusk right and then
the the poetic other side of that would
be Dawn right
cool yeah okay so that's the Crescent
Moon that's cool so more about the moon
uh all evidence suggests and all
theoretical understanding of the
formation of the Moon
helped by the way by rocks we brought
back from by the Apollo program to study
and look at we get a sense of the origin
of that place you guys remember that
that's why America was great
when we did stuff you know because we
didn't mind our tax dollars being used
to make us the greatest nation on Earth
yeah you know but go ahead so we brought
back rocks and we've and we were able to
yes analyze them and realize that the
moon doesn't have much iron in it okay
and an object that size should have much
more iron in it than it does so how do
you make a whole object that is hardly
any iron
so you make it out of a out of a
collision with Earth
but it's sideswipes Earth After Earth
has already sunk its iron to its core
right so when Earth was molten heavy
stuff falls to the middle like stuff
floats to the top gotcha compared to
Iron rocks or light so all the Rocks
floated and the iron sunk iron nickel
gold cadmium all the the heavy elements
they're down there in the core okay so
now Earth has pre-sifted the elements
pre-sifted now you have a a mars-sized
impactor that side swipes the Earth
scattering Earth's crust into a ring
around the Earth
that marsa's impactor keeps going but
the debris mess that it left
continues to orbit the Earth
and the slightly larger bits of this
have more gravity than the slightly
smaller bits so they'll attract more
objects and they get bigger and as they
get bigger they have even more gravity
and they get even bigger and bigger and
it's a runaway exponential growth
the big get bit bigger and the little
ones get eaten eaten thank you okay
so we think over not much time a matter
of months if not only just a few years
Earth had a ring not much unlike not not
unlike Saturn and that ring coalesced
into the moon and that moon was 20 times
closer in the sky than it is today oh
wow well that must have looked beautiful
yeah so imagine that but just imagine
that or it's 20 times wider imagine like
moonrise it was like yeah that's that's
very Star Wars you know like you're
standing there in the desert and you see
like you know a giant a boar in the sky
and you need music to go with that and
that would just totally complete the
scene yeah so it turns out
tidal forces
are very sensitive
to distance
very sensitive in other words not
emotionally sensitive but if you change
the Distance by a little bit it'll have
a much bigger effect than you'd
otherwise think on the strength of the
tides
okay now I can't get over thinking about
emotionally sensitive titles and forces
where all of our oceans are just like
where you go
what did I do
what did I do you said it's you it's not
me but did I deserve this why did right
you just gonna throw away everything we
had
as you slowly Drift Away you're so
distant I don't understand
why we don't communicate anymore
all we have to do is talk why are you so
distant
yeah
there's a space between us exactly
I don't know how to fill this Chasm
between us
all the work here okay
I'm Earth and I can't do all the work
Chuck how many hours of therapy have you
been in with your wife
oh God
by the way I'm the one saying that in
therapy not her
so so so here so mathematically because
you can be mathematically sensitive okay
I just want to broaden your use of the
term sensitivity so the Moon
uh the the mathematical sensitivity of
tidal forces goes as the cube of the
distance oh sweet okay so in other words
if it just went as the distance okay if
it was like 20 times closer than the
tides would be like 20 times higher than
they are today
but no does it go as the distance
squared
that would mean the tides would be 20
times 20 higher than than today what's
20 times 20. oh I don't know 400
Chuck
don't you pull out a calculator you're
on this show you wouldn't tell me what
20 times 20 is
no I'm not doing it
okay you got 400.
however
title forces go as the cube of the
distance
so the cube is you've multiplied by
itself three times so 20 times 20 that's
400 times another 20.
so 400 times 20 that gets you eight
eight thousand
so the tides the oceanic tides on Earth
raised by the moon when the moon first
formed
were 8
000 Times Higher wow than they are today
look at that and and and and and look at
that we're trying to get back there with
with global warming that's wonderful
that's a different problem yeah tell me
about it okay so now Watch What Happens
Tides sloshing on and off the shores
there's friction between the solid earth
and the moving water okay and so Earth's
rotation back then was actually faster
than it is today all right depending on
how far back you you go you can get like
an 18 20 hour day
for Earth not 24 hours look at that okay
so we have a big moon higher ties faster
rotating Earth but the tides are so
ferocious Earth is slowing down oh man
because of it
and in response the moon's orbit is
increasing it is spiraling away from the
Earth
cool and it has been doing that ever
since
we still have sloshing of tides on the
shores Earth's rotation rate is still
slowing down the Moon is still spiraling
away from the Earth
but much slower than it once was
why are you killing me softly if you're
gonna leave just leave
I don't understand it
oh by the way we
had tidal influence on the moon
okay the moon at one time rotated like
anybody else in the in the in the solar
system you'd see the front side the back
side the left side the right side
but our tidal forces on the moon slowed
its rotation down until we locked it
we locked the moon's rotation around the
earth that's why I'm leaving because see
you only see one side of me I'm a
complex person but it seems like you
know when we're together I can only show
you one face check this sounds like a TV
series
why don't you just go why must you make
it so torturing I've been drifting from
you for all these years
you didn't feel me drifting away I mean
seriously
Chuck you can't make a hole
psychological relationship out of this
and you know what this show is called As
the World Turns
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
authentically be the best name show that
ever was ever okay oh God that may be
the stupidest thing I've ever done on
this show laughs
okay okay so so the point is we tidally
locked the moon because we have stronger
tides on the moon than the moon has on
us and so Moon just got locked we slow
down its rotation locked in on it it
only shows one face to us and the other
face we've never seen until we orbited
it with spacecraft the Moon is trying to
do the same thing to us he wants to slow
us down so much that we only show one
face to the moon and the day that
happens we will be in what's called a
double tidal lock nice
as you go that's a nice dance I like it
yeah yeah
so that's so that's what it looks like
Chuck hey man that that's great
that's not Moon Laura that's just
through the moon facts Hey listen that
is that is awesome I mean at the Moon
and the Earth uh locked in the dance so
I have to repeat my one perfect sentence
that I've ever written in my life okay
may I repeat it for you please okay
the rotating planets
orbit the Sun
like pure wedding dancers in a cosmic
ballet
choreographed by the forces of gravity
wow
damn
you wrote that yeah
oh okay
all right
Chuck we got to end it there okay enough
of them we'll give the moon a rest okay
okay and the Earth Moon family
exactly well we'll lead them to their
drama
all right Chuck we got to take a quick
break but when we come back
some of the explaining I'm gonna do is
gonna pick up on an earlier explainer
video on constellations but I only just
scratched the surface way more to come
okay stay with us
we're back Chuck yes we're gonna be
talking about things you thought you
knew about the night sky the
constellations we're going to pick up
where we left off because I wasn't done
with you awesome let's see if you
learned anything from the first session
how many constellations are there oh God
48.
ouch did I get it
no Chuck
I said
what there is many constellations as
there are keys on a piano oh that's
right 88 I got half of it right no
credit
I got the eight right
if we're going to the moon and the
engineer says I got half of it right oh
that's the oh you got there let me get
that code out in space missing your
target you're not coming back I got half
of it right all right so we said some
cool things I think a southern
hemisphere constellations known to
indigenous people from the southern
hemisphere right would be later
discovered by Europeans and when they
named it they had or they were already
deep into the industrial revolution they
started naming them not after mythical
magical creatures but after like stuff
that was enabling the emergence of a new
kind of brand a new like Sexton another
level of civilization there's a section
by the way before the Sextant was
invented which was 60 degrees of a
circle okay there's six of those six
times sixty is 360 degrees what preceded
that was an octant
okay that was an eighth of 360 Degrees
the sky has a Sextant and an octane in
it very nice that feels a little
excessive to me all right you know be
happy with one but know you want two two
out of the 88 constellations are
navigational devices that are kind of
the same you know never have too many
tools you know that's true okay never
so a couple of things
um
what's in your mind the most famous
constellation in the southern hemisphere
oh in the southern
God see so what I was going to say but
that's not Southern was Big Dipper but
everybody knows that yes the north yeah
that's the north okay yeah you're a
southern 8 000 miles off I know
um
no 9 out of ten people say the Southern
Cross I was about to say the cross you
didn't you would not I really wanted to
that no let me tell you something I
really was about to say the cross but I
was scared to do so because one night we
were sitting out and you had your you
know top secret uh Sky pointer
government issue
and you were and you but there's a cross
in the north too yeah that you would and
so that's why I would I was about to say
it cross but okay so there's a northern
cross which we love here in the Northern
Hemisphere and there's a Southern Cross
but they're really different from each
other
okay the Southern Cross is embarrassing
compared to the northern cross oh no
okay the Southern Cross has
four stars in it
okay it's in the shape of a rhombus
uh there is no star there's no at the
transept right yeah so you could have
just drawn a rhombus to remind people
from eighth grade geometry a rhombus
like take a perfect square sit on it
distort the sides and then you get a
rhombus okay so it is a stretch to call
the Southern Cross across it's a stretch
I'm just telling you wow not only that
of all 88 constellations the Southern
Cross is the smallest
oh your thumbnail at Arm's Reach
would completely cover all four stars of
the Southern Cross oh
this is one of the
big delusions there ever was and isn't
there Crosby Stills
uh song Crosby net
um
that's the only line I know because it
has astronomical I'm gonna say I don't
know this song at all but
they didn't sing that in the hood yeah I
was gonna say CSR that's uh you know
it's a little Caucasian food I'm just
saying
I mean don't be wrong but you know so
this I just want to put put it out there
with the Southern Cross now have you
ever met people who have visited the
southern hemisphere anywhere be it
Africa or Australia right and and they
come back and what do they tell you
about the sky
uh I you know I never really got into it
never got it I normally ask him about
the place see that's that's the clubs
how's that exactly you know tell me
about the food what did you see you know
only you would be like and so the night
sky yeah I'm sorry about that nice God
what happens is people visit the
Southern Hemisphere and they come back
and say the southern hemisphere
hemisphere sky is so beautiful yeah it
is so amazing oh my gosh and and so
there's another little delusion going on
there as well
and what is that I don't want to stop
you from liking the southern hemisphere
Sky better than the North I I have no
problems with that
but there are forces operating that
contaminate your data
okay okay do you know how much of
earth's land is in the southern
hemisphere
um I would say not a lot not a lot about
I mean when you look at Africa it's like
that's most of it yes ma okay about 15
of Earth's land mass is south of the
Equator
okay that's also about 15 of Earth's
population
okay so hardly anybody lives in the
southern hemisphere right
so there's hardly any City Lights hardly
any light pollution air pollution all
the things that subtract away from our
experience embracing the sky in the
north does not block your view in the
South so people think the actual sky is
better
because they can see it better
wow
so I'm telling you that the north has
all the coolest constellations
all right you know with the Big Dipper
and you know and the Little Dipper and
the you know and and and Cassiopeia some
constellations straddle the North and
the South Orion is half of the north and
half in the South but when we look at
him he's right side up if you want to
see Orion in the southern hemisphere
he's upside down that there's there's no
excuse for that so I'm just I'm a
northern chauvinist here but I think I
have good reason for it
yeah but the the problem is we can't see
it
I mean you can be as hot as you want you
know but if you're walking around in a
burlap sack nobody's gonna know nobody
knows how hot you are
wow so yeah so this is an interesting
fact about it now here's a so the
northern cross is much bigger than the
Southern Cross and there's a star in the
transept forest right okay and that's an
asterism
an asterism is a set of stars that is
the more interesting subset of all the
stars that comprise the constellation
sweet so
the northern cross is cygnus the swan
the constellation which is not only
those stars in the cross but there are
other stars where you can imagine wings
and it's flying long neck neck Swan
along the Milky Way so it's a beautiful
thought that there's a swan doing this
but it's bluntly across now
last thing I'll tell you there's more
but I just want to sort of put it out
there
um many of the star star constellations
are all Greek and some Latter-Day
technologically related ones but some of
the earliest Navigators were the Arabs
okay the entire Arabian Peninsula all
those folks the very few clouds because
it's desert and so you saw the night sky
and you want to get around there's no
monuments there's no GPS there are no
mile markers how are you going to get
around so they pioneered astrolabes
which was their version of the European
Sextant okay and the octet the astrolabe
they did it first and and it beautiful
works of art with rotating dials and you
hold it up and you can get the Anglo and
their tables and charts it's magnificent
all etched in brass beautiful we have a
collection at the American Museum of
Natural History but one of the largest
collections in the world is at the Adler
Planetarium and astronomy museum in
Chicago
they're one of the largest collections
of astrolabes in the world anyhow any
point is as an homage
who
the
role
Sky two-thirds of all stars in the sky
that have names have Arabic names oh wow
this is part of the sort of
inclusiveness of my field
where if you contributed to it we're not
going to forget you and by the way in
the constellation Libra the scales
um the two brightest stars in that
Constellation Are Arabic names one of
them is Zubin El janubi the other Zubin
eschimali okay those are the two longest
star names of all name stars in the sky
and what is the abbreviation for
pound
lbs lb you know what lb stands for uh uh
no I don't
Libra
the scales it just gets worse
first you go from pounds to lb right
right yeah and lb is a short for Libra
right the measurement of things that's
so cool I Chuck we gotta call it quits
okay have you had enough things you
thought you knew explained to you I
never get enough of explaining okay
there's things I thought I knew and I'm
like I thought I knew but I didn't know
yeah and the stuff you didn't know that
you thought you knew it exactly that
counts I didn't know I thought I knew
this and now I know that I do
and then there's some stuff that I
didn't want to know at all and I still
know it now
occasionally you have to know stuff that
you didn't want to know at all that
happens in life that's that's right and
that'll happen here on things you
thought you knew always good to have you
Chuck it's been Star Talk of things you
thought you knew condition Neil deGrasse
Tyson here
[Music]